class I've seen in yours silent
trained by biology class I'm not powered
on either the graduate school this is
part of our company of scholars lecture
series this year our finger day at
Beverly gauge through the specialist on
Pais 20th century political history
every week is at Yale College grandpa
1994 with metros real american history x
beta cap initials that are really really
good student in 2004 to be seen from PhD
from Columbia University rest area and
will distinction over 2,000 before she
joined the faculty and the Department
the ranks among small professor tenure
in 2012 that's how I got the November
other young faculty members as I serve
on the commercials committee and I was
really excited about the family is
he cries here distinguished result as
well by having covered presence because
she she's already that's what I didn't
even know occurs but was interested to
learn about a 1920 there was a terrorist
attack on Wall Street hero voluntarily
in the United States she has another
book that she's working on it's going to
be available in a couple of years
apparently left on j edgar hoover and
that's the topic of our lecture here
this attic and I was growing up in the
1940s accessories the edgar Hoover was
some kind of a mysterious scary
difficult failure in our society
help us playing that to us here today
thank you all right well thanks to Dean
Pollard into the graduate school to all
of you for coming out on this cold cold
day I am in fact going to be talking
about j edgar Hoover and about this book
that I'm writing right now about j edgar
Hoover and that actually was a sort of
perfect introduction in ways that I
don't think that Dean Pollard even quite
understands because the two themes in
fact of this lecture are how did j edgar
hoover get to be so powerful and who the
heck actually liked j edgar Hoover
during his lifetime so I'm going to
actually start out with a little bit up
here on PowerPoint for most of the talk
I'm just going to be here talking i'm
going to talk for maybe 30 40 minutes
and hopefully leave quite a lot of time
for QA but to start out i have exactly
two slides and really three images that
i wanted to present so when most people
hear the name j edgar hoover these days
one of two of these kinds of images come
to mind so over here we have j edgar
hoover and if you can see him so he's
holding a gun although Hoover himself
was never much of a shot that you had
lots of pictures of him holding a tommy
gun he was never much of a shooter
himself but he's also holding a torn
Constitution in his hand and down around
him you have all the people whose lives
he destroyed in the process of tearing
apart the Constitution socialists union
leaders black leaders Native Americans
third parties and I think this is one of
our two dominant images of j edgar
hoover at the moment j edgar hoover
shredder of civil liberties particularly
destroyer of the American left and much
of what's been written about Hoover has
been in us or the vein of understanding
civil liberties and their violation in
the 20th century the second dominant
image at the moment this is of course
when you tell people you're working on J
Edgar Hoover this is the first question
you get
the question about the dress and about
Hoover's sexuality so this is actually a
cartoon these are a bunch of FBI agents
over here this is a cartoon that came
out in the 1990s and they're saying you
know oh if only Jo drew this is at a
time when there were scandals about the
FBI lab and it's in efficiencies and
they are saying you know if only Jo gir
Hoover were alive we wouldn't be having
this kind of image problem and then
here's Hoover wearing ladies stockings
and high heels coming dancing around the
corner and then they said oh wait a
minute I take it back and this image of
Hoover as both a kind of repressed gay
man potentially a crossdresser certainly
was the dominant image of the movie that
came out last year the movie J Edgar
starring a creepily aging leonardo
dicaprio and that movie really focused
on Hoover's relationship with his
second-in-command the associate director
at the FBI Clyde Tolson I'm going to
talk a little bit about that and there's
lots more to say about that in the QA
but to start out here I actually wanted
to present a third image which is an
image i think that contains its own set
of surprises at this point in the
context of what we know about Hoover i
mean i'm actually going to at least
attempt here to show a one minute long
video and i might even ask you for your
responses when this video is over so i
want to set up a little bit of what
we're seeing here so you probably
recognize this fellow richard nixon who
has his own complicated past and
complicated history as well which we can
talk about but this is richard nixon at
the very end of his first term at j
edgar Hoover's funeral on May fourth
1972 so a couple of important bits of
context before you watch the video
itself at the moment that Hoover died he
was still the director of the FBI and at
that point he had been the director of
the FBI for 48 years became director of
the bureau in 1924 when he was 29 years
old and he died in 1972 at the age of
77 in the same job his extended career
at the Justice Department was actually
even longer than that he entered the
Justice Department in 1917 began really
working intensively with the bureau in
1919 and as I said at the age of 29
became its director so at this 55 year
career at the bureau or at the Justice
Department of which 48 were as director
of the FBI that's one piece of context
second piece of context is this man up
here Richard Nixon and Hoover and Nixon
had a very interesting and long-standing
relationship they met working together
on the Alger Hiss case when Nixon was a
new congressman in the late 1940s and
really provided each other with a lot of
political support and with I think a
genuine friendship at least of sorts
throughout the 1950s and 60s though they
came somewhat to blows once Nixon was
president nixon had actually said at
certain points that he thought he might
try to fire j edgar Hoover and then he
backed down and basically chickened out
and failed to do so but so there's a
long history between hoover and nixon at
this point the last piece of context to
just give you a sense of this kind of
mystery fear to some degree but also
reverence that surrounded j edgar hoover
at the moment that he died in may of
nineteen seventy-two at this funeral the
previous day a Hoover had actually lane
in state in the capital in the Capitol
rotunda he is one of the only civil
servants aside from your military
leaders and presidents is the only civil
servant ever to have been given that
honor and when Nixon goes to give
Hoover's eulogy at his funeral at the
National Presbyterian Church television
stops all three networks actually
broadcast j edgar Hoover's funeral live
and so what we're going to do is just
watch a small clip of of Nixon here
giving j edgar Hoover's eulogy in may of
nineteen seventy-two and then I'll talk
about why I think that's important
the profound principles associated with
his name will not fade away in the time
ahead those principles of respect for
law Order justice will come to govern
our national life mark completely than
ever before because the trend the
permission asst in this country a trend
which edgar Hoover fought against all
his life a trend which was dangerously
roading our national heritage as a
law-abiding people is now being reversed
the American people today are tired of
disordered disruption and disrespect for
long America wants to come back to the
law is a way of life alright so there we
are so I'm curious if anyone has an
immediate reaction to that that clip
that they want to share either people
who remember j edgar hoover from their
own earlier years or i have my own
thoughts about why that's important but
anyone have other thoughts yeah ok yeah
right this is absolutely true so may
1972 Hoover dies June of 1972 is the
Watergate break-in and actually not
going to talk about this a lot in my in
my talk then maybe we can get to it in
the QA I think there's actually a pretty
good case to be made that Watergate
would not have played out the way that
it played out if J Edgar Hoover were
still alive and actually wrote an
article about this so I can tell you
about that if you're curious at the end
of any other reactions just okay yeah so
it doesn't sound like a eulogy and of
course this is the middle of the 1972
campaign so that may be part of the
reason that it doesn't sound like a
eulogy but there's I think a little more
to be said about that any other just
immediate reactions you right right so
this is coming at a moment when
certainly kind of anti-war protest has
been building a building for many years
Nixon has become mired in this and
Hoover has you've seen the first
exposures of the FBI's campaigns against
the anti-war movement as well so maybe
we'll take these two
mm-hmm right so the idea that they are
actually claiming to stand for law and
order while at the same time suppressing
dissent and we have one last one here
said there was very briefly the
embodiment of the kind of law and order
conservatism that was the reaction to
the perceived disorder from 60s early
70s civil rights movements
assassinations protest against the
Vietnam War sexual you know
permissiveness and so forth crime that
really led to this conservative movement
that was great so we also have the theme
of kind of the the birth or I would say
the extension of what was referred to
then and now in want to turn that on as
law and order conservatism so I think
we've actually already hit upon many of
the let's see what happens if I close
that will that just go to sleep all
right well I'm going to leave that up
next I'm not showing a lot more a lot
more slides for the moment there's
nothing too distracting there right okay
so I also wanted to show that clip and
I'll just throw out my three reasons
that I think it's striking to look at so
one is the fact that j edgar hoover in
that moment had a funeral like that
right had a funeral that stopped all
three networks and that he had that kind
of power and influence not only within
Washington but as a kind of cultural and
political icon the second thing that I
think is particularly compelling to me
which is what a lot of people seem to
have seized on here maybe the title of
my talk was a little bit suggestive in
this sense I'm is in fact the fact that
j edgar hoover stood for something and
stood for something that people
recognize
good for a particular kind of politics
stood for a particular kind of political
language and stood I think for a certain
kind of complicated political hypocrisy
as Henry was suggesting but I think it's
more complicated than simply saying
Hoover claimed to be defending the law
at the same time that he was breaking it
the third thing that is particularly
striking to me about that clip is in
fact just how much j edgar Hoover's
image has changed since that moment as I
said we have now these kind of two
dominant icons of him one of him as this
kind of unadulterated villain of civil
liberties one as this kind of
laughingstock the butt of jokes or at
the very least this story of him as a
kind of repressed and sad man who is
playing out his kind of psychosexual
situation on the national stage and I
guess what I'm trying to do in this book
that I'm writing is to take Hoover again
away from these kind of marginal images
of him these images in which he's this
kind of rogue figure in which sees this
one-dimensional villain in which he's
the butt of jokes and bring him back
into the place that he occupied for
better or worse in 1972 and for much of
his career which is at the center or
maybe the center-right of American
politics and that's really what I'm
going to talk about today the question
that in many ways is going to drive my
talk today and I think drives my own
kind of intellectual relationship with
this project is the question of how it
is that a man who was outspoken and
ideologically conservative maintained
the level of power and influence that he
did in the period that we generally
think of as the great age of American
liberalism right as we narrate our
politics in general the period from the
1930s through the 1970s oh it's exactly
the period that Hoover had his greatest
power and influence we often talk about
as the great age of American liberalism
particularly at the federal level so how
do we put these pieces together how do
we want to think
about Hoover as simultaneously an
ideological conservative and someone who
exercised an enormous amount of state
government power during this great
liberal age so that's really the driving
question as I said both of my book in
terms of American politics and in terms
of my talk today before i get into
sorting out some of the pieces of that i
just thought i would say a little bit
more about the book itself and about the
kinds of challenges that come first with
writing a biography and secondly with
writing a biography of a man like j
edgar hoover so i first encountered
hoover as tom suggested when i was
writing my first book which was about a
bombing on Wall Street in 1920 you are
not the only person who had never heard
of this event in fact the impulse behind
my writing that book in the first place
was that I had never heard of that event
and I came across a little mention of it
this was when I was in graduate school
and I thought wow how strange people
were bombing Wall Street in 1920 and
having fairly high numbers of casualty
which seemed like an interesting way
into telling a story about ideas about
capitalism about Wall Street about
resistance to capitalism in Wall Street
and also about terrorism as a form of
political violence that it turns out has
a very very long history in the United
States but in the course of writing that
book I came across this young man who
was there at the then very tiny Bureau
of Investigation within the Justice
Department only had a few hundred agents
who was back there both beginning to
keep files on political radicals and
also was largely running the
investigation into this bombing his
initials are everywhere on those
documents and he was really the
behind-the-scenes guy though he was not
them the head of the bureau running that
investigation and his name was J Edgar
Hoover what this meant I think for me it
was two things so first I was surprised
to see Hoover they're playing such an
important role and expressing at that
point in 1919 and 1920s oh he's about 24
years old at this point expressing so
many of the ideas that are going to
follow him throughout his career
particularly ideas about anti-communism
about the need for law and order in the
United States about the threat of
subversion within the country and he's
really there just had the Bolshevik
Revolution and he's there very very
early on articulating these things
thinking about these things and really
rising through the federal government as
one of the architects of the way in
which the American state thought about
these things it was very striking to me
how early that started and I'll talk a
little bit more about why that's so
striking the other thing that happened
in the course of doing that research was
that I was forced to read a lot of
literature about J Edgar Hoover and in
the course of doing that I realized a
few things the first was that a lot of
it is not really very good that Hoover
is one of these figures who tends to
attract a lot of incredibly obsessive
kind of conspiracy theory approaches so
there's a lot of literature actually
which I now have to plow through because
some of it actually has some some useful
material there but a lot of what had
been written about him had been written
by journalists had been written by
amateur historians so he was someone who
sort of occupied a lot of interest but
there wasn't a very well-developed
literature about him at that point to
the degree that sir serious scholars
serious historian serious journalists
had taken Hoover on a lot of that tended
to fall into one of two camps that
literature during his lifetime much of
it was incredibly agile ettore and I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
ways in which a Hoover was very good at
cultivating journalists giving them
material so that they would in fact
write books in particular that would
reflect his own worldview and after his
death almost all of it has been kind of
counter mythical you thought J Edgar
Hoover was one thing actually it turns
out he's this other thing and if you
look at almost all the biographies of
Hoover they contain the words the
secrets of j edgar
over official and confidential but
they're really about kind of taking down
the myth of Jagger Hoover as it sort of
occupied the American political sphere
for many years the third thing that I
noticed about the literature on Hoover
is that a lot of the best stuff had been
written in the 1980s and 1990s and
there's a very brief period from about
1987 to 1993 when all four of the major
biographies that exist of j edgar hoover
were written in very quick succession
all four of them are actually quite good
and have sort of different different
takes on hoover bringing different
material and different themes to the
four but they were all written in a
particular moment there's sort of a
generational moment in which hoover had
died in the 70s you began to get access
to the files in the late 70s and early
80's and then boom you got this rush of
books that attempted to define hoover
and for the most part were written in
this kind of vein of expose the fact
that it had been about 20 years since a
biography of hoover meant a few things
so the first thing that it meant was
that in terms of materials 20 years is a
lifetime for the kinds of materials that
you tend to deal with when you're
writing about someone like j edgar
hoover right he is not the kind of
figure where you get to find out where
his papers are right this is how
historians work you find out where his
papers are kept and then you go to that
library and you sit down and they're all
there and they're kind of arranged in
folders for you and you make your way
through this this body of files in order
to write about the FBI most of this work
has come through the Freedom of
Information Act and so some of that
stuff is now public and is now publicly
accessible in an easy way other
researchers have have also made their
files public but it's a pretty slow
process it's a pretty laborious process
and so it means that as time goes on we
begin to get more and more and more and
more of this available as more and more
researchers begin to think about doing
this so over the course of 20 years
there's just a whole world of new
material that had come out
just to give you one particularly
dramatic example at the time that the
last set of biographies of Hoover were
written the Soviet Union was more or
less still intact as I said the last
really major biography came out in 1993
since the fall of the Soviet Union we've
had access not only to Soviet archives
which have told us a great deal about
communism and anti-communism
particularly espionage in the United
States but we have also found that the
Soviet Union had the records of the
American Communist Party which we now
which had been missing for many years
the early records of the American
Communist Party we now have access to
that and we have access to things like
the Venona documents which was a secret
espionage project that the FBI in
conjunction with the NSA had conducted
in the 1940s and had kept secret for
many years in which they were decrypting
Soviet diplomatic cables and this is
shed all sorts of new and interesting
light on some of the most famous
espionage cases of that period including
the the outer his case that I mentioned
so that was the first thing that it
meant that there was this whole wealth
of new material that was out there
another quick example just since we
already mentioned Watergate um is the
fact that we now know that mark felt who
was Hoover's third in command at the FBI
was deep throat in Watergate and so this
gives us a whole new lens into how we
want to think about the FBI's
relationship to Watergate its role in
Watergate and Mark felt was there and
sort of took over the bureau at least in
an operational sense at the moment that
Hoover died so there's a whole wealth of
new information about particular cases
in its totality that certainly come out
over the course of the last 20 25 years
so that seemed appealing as well but the
main thing that appealed to me about
writing a new biography of j edgar
hoover really was interpretive and
wanting to take advantage of new strains
in scholarship that had come out over
those 20 years as well and really to
take hoover as i said from the margins
from
being this figure of scandal being seen
as a rogue and a villain and really
think about what role he played in
shaping the American state in shaping
American politics in a much more serious
way and I think in a way that is really
suitable whether you like him or you
don't like him and I think at this point
most people myself included don't
particularly like him though I've got to
know him quite well whether you like him
or not it seems like a moment in which
he needs to be taken seriously and
thought about in this in this broader
way I will say as i mentioned that i'm
not going to go into great detail about
this so i'm happy to answer questions
during the QA about these questions
about his sexuality and he is kind of
identity in in that vein I will say that
that is one area of scholarship that
seemed like it was really ripe to kind
of put the pieces together to think
about Hoover seriously in ways that
would be informed by everything that's
happened in queer studies gay and
lesbian studies as well as in terms of
gender studies thinking about Hoover
around the question of masculinity this
whole world of scholarship that's really
developed over the last 20 or 30 years
is incredibly useful for me and trying
to make sense of Hoover in that vein but
today I'm going to stick to slightly
more formal politics I won't say that
that's not politics because I think that
it is in its own way and i'm really
going to talk about two bodies of
scholarly literature that have been
particularly useful to me and the ways
in which they've both informed my
understanding of hoover and then I think
the ways in which Hoover also tells us
something new and interesting about
those bodies of scholarship so I said
that the driving question of my project
in some ways is really how did an
ideological conservative maintain
enormous state power build and maintain
enormous state power during this period
that we usually conventionally described
as the heyday of American liberalism I'm
going to shorten that
slightly now and just ask how did j
edgar Hoover maintain power for 48 years
he was an unelected bureaucrat right so
he had to be reappointed first in his
early years when it was not a terribly
powerful position by the Attorney
General and then by successive
presidents he was there under eight
different presidents half of the
Republicans half of them Democrats it's
an incredibly long career with an
incredible amount of power so how did
this happen and I think that the
conventional answer and in many ways the
kind of answer that we've gotten out of
this expose tradition is that people
were really scared of him and I think in
many ways for a very good reason as I
said you know a lot of what we've
learned about Hoover over the last 30 or
40 years and to some degree new during
his lifetime though not with the detail
that we know today a lot of what we've
learned are the ways in which he used
the FBI to get people to do what he
wanted collecting you know sexual gossip
on people in Washington collecting
details of people's lives running
disruption operations against social
movements as well as against to some
degree as I said political figures in
Washington as well so there's certainly
a lot of truth to the idea that Hoover
maintained his power through fear and
again to refer back to the film J Edgar
which many of you probably saw came out
a year ago and I think is a good kind of
snapshot of where thinking is at that
point that really was one of the big
themes of the film you know a lot of the
film was was a Leonardo DiCaprio sort of
in a darkened room listening to the
tapes of Martin Luther King and you know
kind of obsessing about Martin Luther
King at any rate there's a lot of truth
to this story and people have done
magnificent research in kind of
ferreting out a lot more of the truth
than we once knew about j edgar hoover
but there are also a few problems with
this immediate assumption that Hoover
held his power only through fear and
only because he had the goods on
powerful people the first is that it
doesn't really explain to us
how it is that he became the man that he
became when we think about Hoover having
the goods on people conducting those
kinds of operations we're really talking
about 40s and the 50s really into the
1960s so how did he in fact become the
man that he became how did he acquire
this power in the first place in the
first half of his career and I think the
second problem with this immediate
reversion to fear as our only
explanation for Hoover's career and for
his power is that it doesn't explain at
least a little bit of what we saw in
that funeral image of Richard Nixon
standing up there it doesn't explain
Hoover's power as a public figure this
kind of mystical figure a household name
and a kind of universally universally
known if never ever universally loved
figure and so I think to answer those
questions we really have to think of
Hoover again not as a rogue figure not
as someone who's operating in secrecy
but as someone whose entire career is
deeply embedded within the history of
the administrative state and the growth
of government in the United States in
some ways this seems like okay well
that's a little bit less interesting
than his secret files but I think it's
really critical to understanding Hoover
and how he operated and in fact I've
come to conclude though my editor is
totally unpersuaded by this when I say
all of the drama is in the bureaucracy
it's all in how the bureaucratic rules
were made she says that is actually not
where the drum is that might be what you
think but nobody else is actually going
to think that's so I am here to make the
case that if this is not where all the
drama is it is really critical to
understanding kind of how Hoover evolves
as an architect and in fact in some ways
a recipient of a certain kind of
tradition of state power so as I said so
that's really the first body of
scholarly literature that I think Hoover
story needs to be situated in this
enormous profusion of scholarship that's
happened really since the 1980s around
the growth of the administrative state
kind of how did
in a democracy how did we get an
enormous federal government most of
which is entirely unelected and in many
cases relatively unaccountable to
electoral power and within that
literature the stuff that's particularly
useful to me is the literature around
the idea of bureaucratic autonomy which
is the question of how is it that
unelected bureaucrats people like Hoover
agency chiefs manage to insulate
themselves from an electoral political
system a political system that evolves
revolves around parties and other kinds
of power how do they in fact achieve
independent power and independent
political basis and in Hoover's case how
do you end up with a 48 year career so
that's sort of the literature in which I
think we need to think about Hoover's
the evolution of Hoover's power and in
some ways he is kind of born to this
government tradition he is an exact
contemporary of figures like Robert
Moses right another kind of who was the
Parks Commissioner of New York right
another man who sort of born at the
right time in the right place to take
advantage of a kind of explosion of
government power but Hoover himself is
actually born in 1895 in Washington DC
he's born five blocks from the US
Capitol and he never lives anywhere else
so in this sense he really is this pure
product of Washington of Washington
politics and he happens to be in the
right place at the right time as the
government begins to grow and
particularly as the security state
begins to grow his first job in the
government is in 1917 as the US is
having this enormous expansion of
government capacities in world war one
and so they're just hiring an entire
generation of new young people to come
in on and to really administer in that
case the war effort on a scale that has
not been seen before and in many ways
Hoover for the first 20 years of his
career is deeply embedded in what many
people would describe as the expansion
of the liberal or the progressive state
so putting aside everything we know
about who he later becomes and to some
degree putting aside the role that
he plays in the first Red Scare of 1919
and 1920 which I can talk about you know
Hoover really comes to his appointment
as bureau director and then lasts
through the 1920s and the 1930s on his
reputation for being an efficient
bureaucrat for being a professional for
being divorced from politics of many of
the same themes and ideas that led to
the creation of other kinds of state
agencies and state bureaucracies so my
argument I guess is that we need to
think about Hoover again not just as a
figure who held held power because he
had the goods on people but as someone
who in many ways was quite typical of
the ways in which state power was built
whether you're talking about a social
welfare agency whether you're talking to
some degree about the military though I
think the military is an exception but
any of the state agencies you see
emerging in Washington in the 20s but
then really in the 30s 40s and 50s I
think we need to understand Hoover in
that vein the second thing that I will
say about the literature on bureaucratic
autonomy that I found particularly
useful is that Hoover is a figure who is
not only very good at getting the goods
on people but he's a figure who knows
how to use certain kinds of techniques
of bureaucracy internally and externally
in fact to give himself an independent
political base so he runs an enormous
propaganda operation throughout much of
his career in which he understands that
if he wants to maintain his position if
he wants to maintain his agency's
reputation he has to appeal directly to
a mass public on a variety of themes
some of which are about professionalism
some of which are about law and order
some of which are kind of about
detective mysteries in the swashbuckling
g-men and some of which are overtly
conservative but so he's very effective
at running that kind of propaganda
operation I think as interestingly he's
also very effective at building his own
political alliances with grassroots
organizations we don't tend to think of
j edgar hoover in that vein but
particular
kind of Club oriented conservative
organizations like the Daughters of the
American Revolution the American Legion
etc they had very great relationships
with the FBI they are sort of back and
forth relationships Hoover legitimated a
lot of their interests often helped
these organizations out and when he was
in trouble they often came to put
pressure on congressman and to write
letters to newspapers in defense of j
edgar Hoover so I think we have to think
about him as a political organizer as
well my last thing that I will say about
j edgar Hoover as a bureaucrat is that I
have become convinced that the single
most important thing that he did in his
entire career in order to maintain power
was not in fact you know knowing about
john f kennedy's affairs or following
eleanor roosevelt and going to franklin
and reporting about who she in fact was
seeing the single most important thing
he did to main power was to keep his
agents out of the civil service system
he fought his entire career to keep his
agents out of civil service and what
this meant was that he was actually able
to build an agency in which he himself
had almost sole control over the hiring
the firing of agents the kind of person
he wanted he justified this not on the
grounds of personal control but on the
grounds of saying that the FBI is so
fabulous and its standards are so high
that they simply cannot take the sort of
mass of people who are being recommended
out of the civil service but again these
kinds of bureaucratic questions these
kinds of State Building questions I
think are as important for understanding
J Edgar Hoover as what files he might
have maintained so that's sort of the
first piece I said so the driving force
at least in part of this biography is
how does an ideological conservative
maintain state power throughout the age
of American liberalism so we've got a
little bit of the power story there I
want to quickly talk about the
literature on conservatism and just
suggest a few ways in which i think
Hoover tells us some new and interesting
things there
so again over the past 20 or so years
young historians in particular have
discovered that there's a whole history
to American conservatism when I right
before I started graduate school my
graduate advisor who was a professor at
Columbia named Alan Brinkley wrote an
essay for our professional journal that
basically started out saying why doesn't
anyone study the history of American
conservatism so this was 1994 you've
gotten through the Reagan years but you
just had you know Newt Gingrich's
revolution of 1994 conservatism is out
there you sort of put out this call and
over the past 15 20 years there's been
an explosion of interest in kind of
writing about conservatism telling this
story without going into a lot of detail
about this the basic story that has
emerged is a story that tends to begin
in the 1950s to revolve both around
social movements organizations like the
John Birch Society and kind of elite
figures like William F Buckley who gets
to start right here in the 40s and 50s
and tell it tends to sort of tell a
story of this surge of conservative
interest of a self-defined conservative
movement kind of coming-of-age in its
first moment with the Barry Goldwater
campaign in 1964 and then kind of
achieving national power in 1980 with
Ronald Reagan this is a story where the
pieces hadn't been put together before
and we've got a lot of great literature
out there about different kinds of
social movements that play a role in
that about the role of business about
the role of intellectuals all sorts of
things but i think that j edgar hoover
actually poses some new questions for us
as we begin to think about this
literature on conservatism so the first
thing that is that as I said Hoover is
articulating the same ideas in 1919 that
he is articulating in 1972 now that this
may just say something about junior
Hoover as a person who was in fact very
rigid very resistant to change but I
think it actually tells us something
more interesting and raises really
interesting questions about how we want
think about the role the conservatism
has played in modern American politics
so Hoover in 1972 is looking back to
nineteen nineteen and saying we're
seeing the same thing we're seeing these
kinds of bombings we're seeing disorder
the same things that Richard Nixon is
saying in that little clip that I showed
j edgar Hoover is already beginning to
use that language in the teens in the
20s and in the 30s so I think his story
suggests that we want to kind of break
apart this story that modern
conservatism comes out of the reaction
to the New Deal and out of the 1950s the
second thing that I think Hoover is
useful for thinking about is that as I
said a lot of the ways in which we tend
to think about conservative politics is
either in an electoral frame or in a
kind of social movement frame right so
you've got the grassroots story this
kind of resurgence that begins in the
50s into the 60s and 70s or you have a
kind of electoral politics story well
Hoover is a very interesting figure in
this regard as I said he's actually
someone who is not sort of operating
outside the Centers of Washington power
he is deeply embedded in them throughout
this whole period and I think it's
interesting to consider and i'll be
happy to expand upon this in the Q&A a
little bit the interesting to consider
Hoover has a kind of conservative state
builder so in what ways do his
conservative politics shape what he does
with in his agency and in what ways do
his conservative politics sort of shaped
the kind of message that he is sending
out into the world on the third piece
that I'll mention quickly is that I
think it's very important to think about
the FBI within the context of this story
of I don't know what kind of battle
between the left and the right
throughout these years or between
liberalism and conservatism because the
fact of j edgar hoover and the kinds of
politics that he had actually meant that
people on the ground activists on the
ground had very very different
relationships to state power it is
fundamentally different experience to be
organizing on the left and we all
probably basically know the story of the
FBI's relationship
with the new left with the Black
Panthers with the anti-war movement
right it's a fundamentally different
experience to fear that your
organization is being infiltrated to
know that the federal government is
watching you and is against you than it
is to be organizing even in a similar
grassroots organization on the right and
know that in some sense the FBI is
behind you that j edgar Hoover is
basically tolerant or supportive of your
politics now I don't think this explains
everything certainly about what's going
on in social movements but to the degree
that we are talking in the 1960s now
about a kind of battle that's emerged
between the left and the right during
those years I think it's important to
see that their relationships with the
state and with the FBI in particular are
not equivalent and that they're very
different on the ground experiences in
part because of this man who is there at
the top in the FBI all right just to
finish up I want to say a few things
going back to our our nixon at Jagger
Hoover's funeral I said you know the
things that stood out to me about that
clip were number one the fact of the
funeral right the fact that this
unelected bureaucrat was able to bring
together the kind of power and interest
and cultural influence that Hoover did
in 1972 and in the years leading up to
that um the second was that he stood for
something right he stood for a
particular kind of conservative politics
and really was a bulwark of that kind of
conservative politics throughout this
period we describe as the age of
American liberalism the third piece that
I just want to say that I mentioned at
the beginning and want to expand upon
very briefly is just how much Hoover's
image has changed since that moment now
certainly there were lots of people who
hated J Edgar Hoover throughout his life
but I think there's something to be
explained in just how dramatically his
image has changed over the last 40 years
and probably the best embodiment of this
for me is that in 1975 this is three
years after he died the FBI finally got
its own building on pence
vania Avenue it had been within the
Justice Department's building previous
to that and when the FBI got its own
building it was labeled the J Edgar
Hoover Building was put up as this kind
of great monument to the great man who
had built the bureau today they are
actually probably going to knock down
that building because it's kind of a
monstrosity you know like mid 70s
terrible architecture looks kind of like
the old New Haven Coliseum so you can
see so they are probably going to move
out of this building and there is an
almost universal assumption that when
they move out of that building and when
they knock that building down you know
the next FBI building is not going to be
called the J Edgar Hoover Building and
in fact there have been battles over the
last 15 to 20 years to actually have his
name stripped off of the FBI building
that is still standing there so I think
on the one hand this is the product of
what I was saying earlier right we do
know more about him right we've had
these expose A's we know more about the
lawlessness and the corruption and the
real venality that the FBI was engaged
in over that time but I think it's
important to store size our own thoughts
as well so I'll just leave you with a
couple of reasons why i think j edgar
Hoover's image has changed so much going
beyond the fact that and we just know
some more of the really problematic
things that were going on the first is
that Hoover happened to die at a moment
of expose right he happened to die as
Watergate is beginning to take off and
this really comes to fruition with
things like the Church Committee and
with other expose A's of the CIA of
other intelligence agencies and new
constraints on intelligence agencies and
in that context I do think probably
deservedly so Hoover emerged as
something of a scapegoat as a person
upon whom you could say oh look at all
of those terrible terrible things that
happened well there's the man who did
them and now he's dead and he was a very
very bad man and none of the rest of us
actually have to take this too seriously
or think about taking responsibility for
it ourselves so I think it is both
served you know truth but has also had
the
effect of kind of absolving other people
of a certain kind of responsibility and
limiting the degree to which we're going
to think in broader terms it was just
that one bad at that very powerful Apple
that bad apple I think the second thing
that's worth thinking about is why
people have become increasingly
interested in Hoover's sex life and you
know I mean it's inherently pretty
interesting on the one hand on the other
hand it is actually I think also a
product of a pretty profound shift
that's happened in how we think about
our public officials and I think to some
degree for the better and to some degree
for the worse in the sense that you know
not only do we not know a lot about j
edgar Hoover's sex life at the time but
we didn't know a lot about what a whole
lot of other powerful people were doing
in their intimate relationships and so
on the one hand it has this kind of
scandalous and interesting quality to it
on the other hand I think we do have to
think about Hoover in relationship to a
broader culture which has begun to take
seriously I think for good reasons and
for bad the the personal lives of its
public figures and how we want to put
those pieces together so I see that I'm
actually I run a little bit over my
prescribed time which was 40 minutes so
i think i will actually just leave it
there for now but last thing that I want
to say is that overall one of the
challenges of writing about Hoover is
that I am trying to write a biography
that takes him seriously and really
looks at his power and his influence
takes his personal life as childhood
seriously at the same time without
writing a redemptive biography of a man
who I think in many ways I had a very
very destructive influence on the United
States and on the shape of its political
culture and on the shape of American
government so I will leave it there for
now hopefully we can do some questions
you